not since the start of the war had
Russia Unleashed such fury on Ukraine on
Monday at least 20 cities were targeted
with strikes on Urban centers and
critical infrastructure wave after wave
of cruise missiles and drones
President Vladimir Putin's revenge for
last week's explosion on the Kirch
Bridge linking Crimea with Mainland
Russia
there are continued attempts to carry
out terrorist attacks on our territory
Russia's responses will be harsh and
their scale will correspond to the level
of threat created for the Russian
Federation no one should have any doubt
about that
threatening language but absent the
kremlin's recent warnings where
President Putin reminded the world of
Russia's nuclear Arsenal and the
potential for using it
still Ukraine's Civic authorities are
trying to make sure they're prepared for
the worst
the response in these cases is simple
when we get a message about a threat we
notify the population stay in houses or
move to protective structures
underground or use PPE if necessary
evacuations may be carried out depending
on radioactive contamination for this
pre-prepared evacuation points are
mostly located in schools
the Kia's residents the safest places
are deep beneath the city's streets
it's a remarkable thing that the Soviets
built these Metro stations as bomb
shelters to protect them from the West
wow if there is a nuclear strike it's
likely to come from Ukraine's former
Soviet Ally Russia
in the early weeks of the war these
stations were full of people taking
shelter and they're equipped for full-on
Armageddon
metal boxes on the floor open and the
shutter Rises upwards
thus the passage is closed and the
station is hermetically sealed people
staying here are completely protected
from the external environment both from
a nuclear explosion and chemical weapons
seeking shelter underground or in
windowless interior rooms evacuation
points how to avoid breathing in
radioactive dust it's doomsday advice
from a bygone era updated for right here
right now and modern digital technology
but some still feel ukrainians are
underprepared and unprotected
runs Ray of Freedom he's fundraising to
provide survival kits free of charge for
all
my goal is to make ukrainians conscious
about it for everyone to have a kid for
themselves because we live next to a
dangerous neighbor and you never know
what is on someone's mind in the Kremlin
for most people the consequences of a
nuclear strike are Unthinkable yet
ukrainians are having to think about
them Rory challenge Al Jazeera Kiev
[Applause]